- Au coeur du secteur Ste-Foy
à Québec, il y a une petite
église : l'église Saint-Mathieu.
Ici, le dimaoioioioir, la messe
est célébrée en espagnol.
L'abbé Pierre Gingras est
responsable de la paroisse.
Abbé PIERRE GINGRAS, curé
responsable de Namamamame-de-Foy
- On retrouve beaucoup
d'immigrants. Les populations
africaine, hispanophone,
portugaise...
Onmemememe des Malgaches.
- Il y a six églises
dans la paroisse,
mais il y a assez de fidèles
pour en remplir une seule. L L ,
qui représentent le tiers
des adeptes, permettent
toutefois d'en maintenir
quelques-unes en vie.
GILLES ROUTHIER, professeur
titulaire, Université Laval
- Si on regarde à partir
des chiffres et à partir
des nombres, on va dire
que c'est une église en déclin.
- Le nombre de prêtres,
de religieuses, de fidèles,
le nombre d'églises et la
santé des finances; tous ces
indicateurs sont à la baisse.
En 1984, des centaines
de milliers de Québécois
acclament et célèbrent
le pape Jean Paul II lors
de sa visite dans la province.
Les messes font salle comble.
La moitié des catholiques
participent au moins une fois
par mois à des activités
religieuses. Près de 4
plus tard, ce taux a diminué
de moitié.
L'abbé Gingras a lui-même fermé
trois églises, et il sait
l l l l en fermera d'autres.
- Ah, c'est dramatique.
- Vraiment, il y a eu une
accélération du décrochage,
à partir des années 80.
- De 1920 à 1960, la religion
catholique est à son apogée,
au Québec. L'Église est alors
responsable de l'éducation,
de la santé et des services
sociaux, ce qui lui donne
le pouvoir de définir un bon
nombre de normes morales
chez les Québécois.
- La paternité de l'Église
sur la société québécoise,
on veut s'en affranchir.
- Pierre Gingras remarque
d'ailleurs que ce sont
particulièrement
les baby-boomers
qui ont déserté les églises.
- On voit, en majeure partie,
des gens agés,
et on voit des jeunes.
- C'est le cas d'Antoine
Malenfant, 3 I I I Il fréquente
l'église deux fois par semaine.
Il y a rencontré sa conjointe,
avec qui il a eu huit enfants.
ANTOINE MALENFANT
- J'attends le neuvième
et le dixième.
C'est écrit gros de même
dans ma face que pour moi,
ce que l'Église enseigne,
en termes de morale sexuelle,
j'adhère à ca.
- Que les églises soient vides,
ça luitetetete peu. Il apprécie
que les fidèles qui se déplacent
le fassent par choix
et conviction.
- Je dirais qu'il y a moins de
gens qui y vont par convenance.
Autour de moi, il y a plusieurs
jeunes familles qui fréquentent
l'église, puis elles
le font par choix.
- Des jeunes fidèles comme lui,
il y en a peu, constate Gilles
Routhier. Selon lui, les
leleleles sexuels de prêtres
pédophiles et les pensionnats
pour Autochtones ont contribué
au déclin de la popularité.
- Ça entre dans la consonononon
de l'idée que tout ce qu'a
réussi l'Église, c'est d'abuser.
PIERRE BOLDUC, victime alléguée
- C'est sûr que ça a pas aidé,
la pédophilie.
Mais comment le quantifier?
On ne le saura jamais.
- Dans les années 60, Pierre
Bolduc dit avoir été agressé
sexuellement à de nombreuses
reprises par le curé de sa
paroisse. Lui, en tout cas, a
perdu sa foi pour cette raison.
- Il y a un de mes oncles
qui m'a demandé, il n'y a
pas longtemps... Il m'a dit :
"Pierre, est-ce que tu as perdu
la foi?" J'ai dit : Bien,
qu'est-ce que tu en penses?
- Ce n'est pas la première foi
de son histoire que l'Église
catholique passe à travers
une période difficile.
- De penser que c'est te
c'est une grande illusion.
Il faut s'attendre à une
longue traversée du désert.
- Ici Marie-Piererererer